if you ask the typical Cloud engineer
would you like to use infrastructure as
code in 100 the answer will be yes but
what we see right now is that only a new
project people are embracing
infrastructure as code because they are
as that technical debt of the stuff that
they are already put in the cloud and
they are not putting the time and effort
to codify them and this is exactly where
Firefly is coming handy so we're saying
it's not just the Green Field kind of uh
project when you want to use the the
best of the technology like
infrastructures code let's take the
entire Cloud the stuff that you put two
years ago three years ago and create
infrastructure is good for you so you
can enjoy all of the benefits of
infrastructures code
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek hello and welcome to 20 minute
leaders today I am with Iran Bibi the
co-founder and chief product officer at
Firefly with years of experience in
anything devops he has earned a
reputation as a cicd expert and an avid
admin of cloud platforms and
containerized environments
[Music]
Iran Bibi welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here how are
you I'm amazing thank you for having me
though how are you thank you I'm doing
very very well thank you where we're
talking about a subject that I that I
care about a lot we're talking about
obviously Cloud infrastructure bringing
clouds up to date today today with
firefly but before that it's been you
have had a long journey working the
devops the ICD and being a strategic
thinker in these areas and so I'm
looking forward to get gaining your own
perspective on where wrap the space
where the different opportunities what
are the different gaps that we've
observed in the market and just recently
somebody reminded me that still most of
the world is on-prem which is kind of
weird for me growing up to a world where
I don't know what a server is I just
know what AWS is yeah right so it's a
it's weird to me as well because in our
you know small ecosystem here on East
well in specifically in the Tel Aviv
startup area everything is in the cloud
right and most of the engineers
basically born in the cloud so yeah
telling the fact that most of the
compute is on-prem uh in 2022 is a bit
weird
right right so so how do what what is
happening just gave me maybe a a broad
picture of the world today
2022 what's the state of cloud today so
I think in the past 10 years there was a
rush to cloud computing because all of
the advantages of uh basically uh giving
the provider to manage all the
infrastructure and all the automation
around that and this use Advantage uh
were helping businesses to get uh more
uh software delivery much much faster
with less people involved in
infrastructure and networking and
storage and other kind of uh professions
that we are nearly see today
and
if you tell me what is the state right
now I will say it's a bit chaotic
because the transition to the cloud was
very very fast and
something very significant in the
landscape is the short of talent the
shortage of talents that we have uh
specifically in cloud computing and in
devops methodology and this caused a lot
of challenges new challenges that the
organization didn't faced before that
so I want to delve on this point because
uh you're mentioning you're using the
word chaotic and then you're mentioning
that the transition to Cloud will happen
very very quickly it almost feels like
you're saying it was too quick it was
too fast
I think it was uh pretty much natural uh
in the face that
um
organization decide to transition to the
cloud because at the beginning there was
some barriers around that because some
security concern but because the vendors
the the huge vendors like AWS and
Microsoft were able to force that even
uh government can host their uh
facilities in the cloud so everybody
understand that there is no uh any
barrier to move to cloud computing the
pure advantages right
so once it's done and I think it was
like the the main Milestone was around
like four years ago everybody tried to
build something on the cloud whether
they have uh the the engineering
capacity to do that and the knowledge or
not they just put stuff on the cloud
sure yeah and and then you mentioning
that there is a you know there's a
strategy to it there is order there's a
different mechanisms that make it I
guess a more healthy way of being in the
cloud rather than not and so it all it
felt like you're mentioning that at
least to me felt that because of the
speed at which we've transitioned to the
cloud now we're stopping and we're
saying wow okay actually we have to we
have to think again about what
infrastructure we built here how we're
organizing our Cloud infrastructure and
what are the best practices and we may
not be using them right now
right I think it's all about whether you
are properly utilized in the cloud
because everybody put stuff in the cloud
very fast most of the times it was not
that efficient it was not optimized it
was not uh very secured that's why you
see a lot of cloud security company
raising uh nowadays and right now I
think it's the phase that cloud
computing and adoption become more
mature
so it's not just putting stuff on the
cloud instead of putting it on Prem you
just I should do it right how to do it
in a scale how to make sure we have the
right uh people and training for the
people to do it properly yeah
right and so
tell me a little bit about your own your
own background and entrance to to Cloud
you know you as an engineer you can
choose to to get excited about a variety
of Technologies what is it about the
cloud that that really gets you going
so um I mean the business something like
uh 17 years and in my background I did
most of uh system engineering and
infrastructure Administration and when
Cloud became a thing uh something like
10 years ago and you saw that software
development development being involved
with infrastructure and that was
basically the concept of DeVos of how to
automate Stuff how to do stuff using
your engineering skill as a developer
and I found myself very intrigued by
this concept of
uh not just doing the operational and
the monitoring and the art core
infrastructure stuff also doing
software life cycle development like
cicd and
it's like devops was built directly to
the stuff that I want to do in my life
and I was uh basically embrace it and um
just willing to be more and more
professional on that specific uh
methodology
is that is it stemming from um this
personal agency to affect great change
within organizations is it stemming
mainly from a curiosity about you know
what these organizations are you know
how what are the best practices so what
is sort of the driving force for you
what in relation to this technology I
think it's for me it's like enjoying uh
enjoying Both Worlds like from one end I
really like infrastructure and servers
and operating system and the stuff that
is uh less development oriented but in
the other end I really like scripting
and light coding and this is stuff that
as a system administrator did a lot like
uh uh python scripting and shell
scripting and stuff like that and devops
is basically combining those two skills
into uh um one achievement to make
software deploy faster into the cloud
got it and and is it is it in more
watching alone working with the team
what what do you enjoy more
I really enjoyed uh enjoying the
Education and Training around that as
someone that did that profession
um in the early stage of devops I really
enjoy being involved in the community
and doing talks and explaining and
basically evangelist devops
and telling the world why it's uh this
is the better way uh uh to manage
software in the clouds and all of the
fractics around it and you know there is
tons of Technologies involved and each
year there is a new new kid on the Block
like new technology that develops
engineer me to master so it's really
fast moving kind of experience for me
I love it so and I'm and by the way I'm
sure that also the conversation has been
shifting over the last few years from
that of cloud is good to know okay how
do we actually make it amazed right so
you we started the conversation saying
me there's an agreement
that cloud is undisputedly better than
the non-prem for a variety of reasons
but now you're saying the conversation
the interesting conversation is okay but
how do we do it really really well and
that's where you come and you bring your
own insights right right I think one of
the main challenges that we are facing
uh in the last year is uh the dependency
that organization and development team
uh add with
those Cloud professions uh professionals
devops engineers and that dependency
cause uh stuff to be slowed down so
instead of devops be the enablement and
the the function in the engineering that
will help to drive right faster
it's become like a burden because you
don't have enough devops in relation to
the engineers and then you are slowing
down so I think this is something that
right now organization trying to solve
it makes sense I mean it's sort of like
this function within the organization
that holds the key to the box and
there's a deadlock on this key and we
have to find better you know if we're
going back to operating systems type of
ideas how do we how do we create better
better mechanisms for unlocking this key
and for for allowing anybody to do
things but but on the other hand I also
saw that there were organizations that
are going for more autonomy to the
average engineer to be able to manage
their own cloud service well that comes
back to bite them in the ass in a
different way obviously because they
don't use the best practices right
exactly because you know when you put it
on paper it sounds amazing you say
everybody should know devops because
devops is not a profession it's a
methodology it's a culture it's
something that you need to embed in the
DNA of the engineering team
but then when reality hits you
understand that the typical software
engineer would like to write software
would like to do business uh kind of
feature
and that devops task is basically
a burden for him yeah so it's not for
everybody yet there is a lot of
Engineers that enjoying doing devops and
uh don't need to be dependent on anyone
because they have the right skills and
the right mindset but the the majority
of engineering when they have a new
Sprint coming and they need and they
have their assignment for the Sprint
it's a business oriented and the devops
is just you know
some other tasks they need to do and in
most of the case they will prefer to lay
off that task to somebody else that this
is his profession this is what he's
doing for his living and this is like
his expertise and he will do it better
and quicker than him because he has the
the access and the permissions and the
knowledge
and um
so I think that concept of everybody
doing devops is not really aligned with
what's happening in in most of the
organizations
so Firefly where where does this catch
you what is how do you see this world
what is this sort of pain point that you
identifying that you wanted to solved
with a firefly
so the story in Firefly
um
he's a very nice story I was uh in a
position in my previous company where I
was managing uh devops team and platform
engineering and I did a very nice uh uh
career on that direction of being a
leader in the engineering team
but then I was met uh you know which is
my co-founder and uh Safi which is the
CTO of uh Firefly and they
well for Consulting with me about the
idea that they have to automate some of
the tasks for devops with the mindset of
how to make the cloud better for devops
engineers and it's more really
pinpointing on some of the paints that I
was having uh during the past decades
about
you from one end you want to put stuff
very fast in other end you need to make
sure it's properly aligned with the best
practice and um
Firefly is basically introducing uh the
solution for that
and so what is the actual product that
you're building
so we are scanning uh The Cloud of the
user we are a multi-cloud multi-account
system we are providing visibility about
all of the configuration and assets that
the user have and we provide a very nice
metric that say
how much percentage of the cloud is
being managed by infrastructure as code
versus the stuff that you created
manually
using like a click Ops kind of
methodology like the the bad way of
putting stuff in the cloud and then with
our technology we were able to create
automatically code for the missile fart
or the cloud and what we are doing is uh
going to organization and help them to
increase the infrastructure is code
coverage in an automated way
and making sure that and by the way why
is that useful why is why is this why
have you identified that this is a
critical piece of of the of of what a
company should be doing
because when you are talking about
provisioning Assets in the cloud right
now the best way to do it and uh this is
something that we see in the past few
years is using infrastructure as code
you're basically leveraging all of the
benefits that have a code lifecycle with
peer review with cicd gating with all of
the tools that you can put before
provisioning into an infrastructure
and there is a very nice uh and popular
framework to drive this like terraform
and Polo me and cloud formation
and
if you ask the typical Cloud engineer
would you like to use infrastructure as
code in 100 the answer will be yes but
what we see right now is that only a new
project people are embracing
infrastructure as code because they are
as that technical debt of the stuff that
they are already put in the cloud and
they are not putting the time and effort
to codify them and this is exactly where
Firefly is coming handy so we're saying
it's not just the Green Field the kind
of project when you want to use the the
best of the technology like
infrastructure as code let's take the
entire Cloud the stuff that you put two
years ago three years ago and create
infrastructure is good for you so you
can enjoy all of the benefits of
infrastructures code
and is the I guess this is selling it
more top down in terms of go to market
uh so because you're looking
strategically at how a company operates
from an infrastructure play versus a you
know single spontaneous flick play
so it's a great question and we are
basically tackle uh both directions our
platform is a field G oriented we have a
self-service you don't need to contact
anyone in Firefly in order to enjoy it
we have a free tier that basically any
any any small team can enjoy and we have
our like unlimited offering open uh for
21 days so you to explore and see all of
the benefits of for a flight but we also
doing direct sales like address trying
to reach out to those specific uh uh
personas that if those space like the
director of devops the head of devops of
uh a certain organization
interested
as uh as you imagine yourself
integrating into more and more of these
companies
how do you see the cloud World shifting
simultaneously do you see this problem
getting bigger getting smaller do people
are people converging
on this idea do you find that they're
diverging and you need to bring them in
in other words how aligned is where you
are now versus how the world is Shifting
With or Without You
we are in the infrastructure as code
space right so this is right now uh at
least as we see at the beginning
of the transition so we see a lot of
traction around it there is a lot of new
startup in the ecosystem and we also see
ashicor which is a great company that
basically introduced terraform this is
the most popular framework for
infrastructure is code become huge
company public company they they were
ipoing uh six months ago
and
um
from that perspective we see that we are
in a very good place
go back to your own uh to your own you
know reason for doing this in your own
your own interests and curiosity you
know what what do you enjoy most and
what you're doing now is it the you know
entrepreneurial side
um the the development side the thing as
a thought leader in the space well what
is sort of the driving force for you to
go and start your own company
there is few but I think uh the most uh
uh major one will be the shift in from a
position where I am more in charge of uh
engineering execution for product
management
role where I need to uh be more
in the business front and talking with
customers and doing a strategic roadmap
and stuff like that so this is the major
shift at least for me and again as a
devops engineer there is a lot of emails
to link that we are building so
I think I had a relatively good
experience with building products but
this is the first time that I'm actually
uh doing a product management role again
I am interested people that help that I
recruit that helped me uh with this but
this is um relatively new to me again
I'm doing it in the past year and I
really really enjoy it
I love it and then it's I I it just
sounds really cool how are you taking
you know personal interest you're taking
a shift in the world
um identifying the potential then coming
and bringing it together while learning
new skills and and finding new things by
yourself so that's just very very cool
and I wish you best of luck with firefly
Iran thank you very very much for being
here in these 20s short but but also
minutes so thank you very very much and
best of luck with the Firefly thank you
Mithun
thank you